where should you live in a zombie
apocalypse
as with most things location is
everything and not all communities on
the walking dead are created equal
here is a ranking of each one from worst
to best
huge points get taken off for this
community because they don't allow
themselves to settle down
this faction decided early on that they
didn't want to bother with hanging on to
the world that was
instead they decide to cede control of
the planet to the zombies by living
among them
rather than build walls to keep the
walkers out they wear cured flesh masks
that allow them to blend in with the
dead
even strategically hurting them for
their benefit at times
part of their philosophy is that
humanity needs to get back to its more
animalistic roots therefore
they operate on a societal basis of
hierarchy with an
alpha leading their every move and
making all their decisions
although they successfully eliminate
walkers as a threat to their daily lives
it just doesn't feel like a great way to
live the worst part
is that a whisperer is always at the
mercy of their alpha
if alpha decides the herd is moving one
way that's the way they're going if
alpha decides to start a war with
well-armed humans
they're going to war in short there's
not much difference between a whisperer
and a regular zombie
other than technically freedom that we
are the walking dead this is a great
example of something that sounds
terrific on paper
being absolutely awful in practice at
the onset of the apocalypse a handful of
police officers in atlanta
manage to maintain their rank in society
amongst the hospital skeleton crew
as the city falls into anarchy their
leader don lerner has the respect of her
fellow officers due to her rank which
means increasingly less with each
passing lawless day
eventually supplies dwindle and don
implements a system of taking survivors
in for medical treatment
only to force them to pay off the debt
they've incurred for being saved
unable to keep the tense community
afloat don resorts to more hostile
measures basically enslaving anyone that
the police find
in a world where humanity is scarce and
decisions are being made on a life or
death level
having to defer to the judgment and
power of a former law enforcement
officer
just sounds like a nightmare for dawn
and her citizens
life becomes about serving a singular
goal keeping her
in power that seems like a great deal
for dawn less so for everyone else
woodbury gets credit for being one of
the first safe havens built from the
ground up
after the onset of the apocalypse early
on in the show's timeline
the governor leads a small group of
people to clear out fortify
and make the town somewhat
self-sustaining at a time when most
other people were wandering the woods
under the governor's leadership they
even managed to plant crops and get the
power back on so that some small slice
of normal life was restored to a little
more than 70 people
however although comfortable the
residents of woodbury are completely
unaware of the day-to-day danger they
face
mostly from their insane leader i'm
sorry it's just this place is
[Music]
i can't stay here why the governor he is
not what he seems to
be the viewers know the governor to be a
heinous individual capable of horrific
crimes
however the average person who sees
tomatoes growing in their neighborhood
probably isn't looking too closely at
where the latest shipment of supplies
came from
this ignorance comes to a head during
the war with rick grimes's group in the
prison
the citizens of woodbury think
themselves the good guys when they
launch their attack but some of the
survivors of the battle are cut down by
the governor himself
not exactly a community where you can
depend on your leader
once you survive the apocalypse the
question becomes what kind of day-to-day
life is acceptable for you to survive in
for the members of the scavengers the
answer to that question has a pretty low
bar
while the people around them are
clearing out prisons factories and small
towns
a woman calling herself jadis decides to
claim a junkyard
on paper it sounds bad however if you're
looking to survive
it provides security as well as
resources like scrap metal and even some
food
meanwhile jadis's policy of rarely
risking her people's lives
or even revealing their presence to the
world means that they avoid conflict
while living in relative comfort with
plenty of essential supplies
eventually though the war in the area
becomes so large
that jadis and her people fall into the
hands of the saviors
until then however jadis has a
resource-heavy community full of loyal
people who stayed out of sight and
therefore out of mind they were even
making groovy artwork and adopting weird
eccentricities like
only speaking in broken english these
are things that people have the luxury
to experiment with
when safety isn't really a concern
speaking of odd diction choices in the
apocalypse
the kingdom takes the cake by forcing
its most loyal members to adopt a
renaissance fair style of english as
they pledge fealty to their founder and
king ezekiel
what do you think of the kingdom carol
what do you think of the king while
having to perform a character as family
members die
and society crumbles all around you is
challenging to say the least
the kingdom is one of the nicer places
to live early in the apocalypse
ezekiel sees potential in an abandoned
school and fortifies it as a place to
build a community
unfortunately it isn't around a lot of
natural resources
nor is it in the most defensible spot
however that doesn't stop him from
putting in the work
and turning it into a self-sustaining
safe haven unfortunately
his hold on the kingdom is interrupted
by the saviors coming in and demanding a
piece of the pod
it doesn't take long before the
resources and good nature of the kingdom
and its citizens dwindle
while the community gets credit for
changing with the times the fact is that
ezekiel invests
long term in a place with a short
expiration date
the prison may seem like a great place
to live and rick and his group of
survivors do their best to make it one
for a long time
however the logistics of maintaining a
prison are a constant struggle
for one the place was designed to be
maintained by a large staff of guards
cooks administrators and more when in
doubt
prison labor filled in the gaps when the
survivors arrive
it's up to a little more than a dozen
people to manage a massive facility
while blocking off a section of the
prison is easy enough they are
constantly plagued by walkers getting
past the gate
meanwhile its curbside appeal makes it a
constant target for attacks which is
ultimately how the prison
falls in a desperate world having
something as shiny and secure as a
prison
is too often an invitation for outsiders
to take what isn't theirs
a place can be as safe as possible from
walkers but as the show constantly
reminds its audience
human beings are the real threat in this
world
the community of oceanside is created
after another settlement falls to the
ruthless tactics of the savior simon
after suffering a defeat that sees every
male member of their society executed
the women and children flee to
re-establish themselves elsewhere
they become the first group on this list
to utilize their natural geography
by putting the ocean at their back to
prevent walkers coming at them from
every side
they decide that sharing what they have
with the world is no longer an
option because someone like simon will
eventually strong-arm their way into
taking it
as a result they spend most of their
time doing the bare minimum to survive
while getting rid of anyone that might
make their presence known to the rest of
the world
unfortunately their main concern is
staying hidden which prevents them from
really building the oceanside community
into something grand
until after rick's war with negan even
then
resources are scarce and oceanside
becomes little more than a stopping
point for people to travel to more
secure locations
however the community gets a lot of
credit for being naturally fortified
from the water as well as standing tall
in the face of defeat
oceanside also gets top marks for its
resilience and tactical position
fortified walls an endless supply of
fighters resources
and a somewhat merit-based economy if
that sounds like a good time
the sanctuary might be up your alley of
course it's not all sunshine and
lollipops members of the sanctuary are
asked to join an incredibly unforgiving
cult that promises safety in exchange
for entering a debt system
similar to that of grady memorial
hospital if you decide that you're not
happy with the deal
you can always run however negan and the
saviors are powerful enough to collect
on their debts
unfortunately all it takes is a run-in
with rick grimes for everything to
crumble
the problem with ruling by fear is that
once you encounter someone that isn't
afraid to take a few hits you can't just
take your ball and go home
negan understands that which is why he
wages total war on rick and his alliance
of communities
he knows that there is no way to
continue ruling by force if there is an
equally powerful civilization in the
area with a more enlightened view on
corporal punishment
similar to the sanctuary terminus is a
large brick facility that is easily
fortified and manned by people to ensure
the dead state out
its people don't even need to risk
venturing out into the world for
supplies
everything they need in terms of weapons
equipment and yes food
is delivered right to their front door
after resorting to cannibalism following
a horrific attack
leader gareth advertises terminus as a
safe haven for survivors
that's just the sales pitch however
anyone who makes it to terminus has to
give up their gear before getting made
into a feast for real terminus residents
gareth builds a society that is
sustainable and secure
however the cost of entry is becoming a
straight up cannibal
one can only survive so long on morally
questionable societal means
but gareth manages to make it last for a
surprisingly long time
this safe haven has literally everything
alexandria is a community that was
converted from an upscale suburban
neighborhood
originally designed for sustainability
once the apocalypse hits
a professor of architecture redesigns
and fortifies the walls to ensure that
both
people and walkers can't get in there's
enough space in empty houses for people
to really set down some roots knowing
that they don't have to worry about the
wasteland outside
plus its location near a mall means
years of guaranteed supplies before
needing to look elsewhere
in short alexandria ticks off all the
boxes of both safety and comfort
however being comfortable and safe isn't
always the best thing for people in an
apocalypse
similar to the prison when you have
something that looks this great to a
desperate outsider
it will forever be a target since
settling down in alexandria its citizens
have done nothing but fight the outside
world to varying degrees of success
still if you like a lot of danger and
excitement in your life
alexandria might be the place for you it
may not be the flashiest
it may not be the most comfortable but
it's definitely survived and thrived
more than any other community with more
potential the hilltop starts out as a
historic museum house in virginia before
the apocalypse turns it into a safe zone
when the military abandons it the
survivors decide it's the perfect place
to build a stronghold
its location in the wilderness means
that large invasions by walkers aren't
likely
and easy to see coming if the impossible
does occur survivors can't really sneak
up on the place and if they did
they'd have large walls and guards with
weapons to contend with
the community is even self-sustaining
with fertile ground and dependable crops
without the need to venture outside
however the true strength of the hilltop
is in its leadership
for all his flaws gregory was the exact
person hilltop needed to establish and
secure the safe haven
however when he proves ineffective as a
wartime leader the people are lucky
enough to see maggie take charge
when all else is failing around them the
hilltop digs in and manages to survive
while other more seemingly secure and
stock communities
fall like dominoes not only is it a
well-built place to live
but it's led by people who are just
hardened enough to keep it safe without
resorting to drastic measures
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite television shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one